thank you very much for uh listening
into this talk uh that I'm giving right
now so um first of all before I start I
always said that this system probably
the most important slice well this is
like applied to when I'm giving a live
talk right because people will be like
you know putting the phone and then you
know taking pictures and stuff so I
always said that like with this lie you
don't need to worry about that because
all the slides would be on slice.com in
at the link at the bottom but since this
is probably recorded So maybe there's
less worry about people have to be
distracted themselves with taking
picture of the slide so I without
further Ado I would move forward and go
ahead so
um
do you know what is skill so uh usually
I ask people to show a show of hand do
they know what skills like have a better
idea of like you know what the audience
know and what they don't know I guess
you can like do it now on the chat if
you want to but you're not required to
to do that and also there are delays and
stuff but uh don't worry I will make
sure that everybody is on the same page
and I will explain a little bit of what
the skill and why we care about this in
a bit but before that I would like to
introduce myself so I'm Chuck I work for
Anaconda
um so it's really really exciting to be
here and talking to you all through this
like amazing online technology and uh
also I love open source project I
involve in open source project in the
past those are in the past right now I'm
actually like helping a lot of people to
understand more about like what they can
do with like using other tools uh to
make the data science life much better
also I uh you know uh love the community
I've been to a lot of conference
speaking a lot of conference and
organize some of them as well
um so yeah if you meet me in person in
the future please come say hi I really
appreciate that I love talking to people
so uh yeah so you know come to talk to
me
um
so
like I promised I'm gonna make sure
everybody know what is the kill so I'm
gonna talk about that in a second so
what is a guilt like what is that stand
for like it's well I put it all capital
here so it probably is like Gil is you
know something that's the initial of
some terms or words right so it's
actually stands for Global interpreter
log so Global interpreter log uh is
something that is quite unique in Python
um because in Python uh for those of you
who who don't know um so in the computer
nowadays especially if you kind of let's
say you buy a new computer it says like
oh you have how many calls that you have
right so right now recently you know
there's Black Friday and I go to like
look at Apple Store and like looking for
a new laptop for myself and um I see
like now you know the newest model you
can get like eight or ten course so it's
like wow a lot of course so what does
that mean so that means that
um a lot of process in your computer if
it's support multi-threading that you
could actually not just use one CPU but
multiple CPU to get the job done so wow
you know it's it's like you know in a
project if there are more people working
on it so it may be like you know it'll
get the job done faster
but the problem is that you know uh it's
like teamwork you have to really like uh
have a very good um design of how people
can work together how this like you know
CPU because they work together but not
like tremble on other people's toes
um so in Python things are a little bit
complicated so by Design right by Design
so python will have this Global
interpreter log basically it's locking
that the whole python itself is going to
be only uh one thread is going to work
on python so when python you know uh so
like because actually python is also a
program if you don't know that if you
download python um actually python is a
program that read your python code and
then we'll just like carry out the
instructions like uh you know from your
code right so the global interlock
basically make sure there's only one
thread that's going to read your code
and execute a code so there's no
tripping on other people's toe because
things can get messy if there's no more
than one threat accessing your program
so uh so yeah only one thread can be
accessed so I've come ahead of my time
and already talked through this point
um
so uh things get messy when there's more
than one threat that actually work on
your code because you know a lot of
python objects they are mutable
um they are actually like you know for
example dictionary or list
imagine like sometimes you know if you
have multiple threats and they can get
mixed signal right because you may you
know you assume that your python code
this like you know if you're not writing
async or any code like that it's just
like you know execute one instruction at
a time but you know if imagine if like
you know two threads getting two
instructions and they're trying to
change one object together at the same
time
you know we think it happens so we don't
want that we want the lock to make sure
that our program run just like what we
expecting
um
so that that's that applied to python so
python the solution of python like uh
now with the you know standard
distribution of python you know the
solution is that we have this goal in
terms of the lock so it's only one
thread it's doing the python thing so
it's like no other friends so the other
fret can do other things at the
background if you have multiple things
running in your computer but for python
only one thread is going to do that
um so uh other you know like uh but
that's the Not the Only Solution that's
what python is doing for other uh
programs other computer programs they
may uh actually support multi-threading
so that they actually like they have
multiple threats one thing that process
of running that you know things so so
it's it's not uh so it's not something
that like we absolutely cannot do
so that's why we bring up to this talk
um so there's a no-q version of hyphen
so what does that mean
um so this Nokia version that I'm
talking about today is uh especially one
uh version uh that I'm talking about is
a clone of python 3.9
I know I know right now it's like
because now we are in three eleven it
sounds a bit old but it's okay just
trust me just you know I would talk
about that in a bit
um so this is actually the newest
attempt to remove the gear so to have no
gear python actually their previous no
gear python version that is done by
other like very small genius people in
the past you know uh they they have all
tried to attempt to remove the giving
python
um because you know we're gonna try
something that maybe can make python
faster but this version the newest
version is done by uh Sam gross uh he's
also a genius he's like you know he gave
a talk in your python this year that's
why I was inspired and I want to like
you know try it out myself and kind of
discover what is about
um so uh well again like why we're
talking about no gear right why why it's
like pivot is okay right now it's like
okay as is like why do we want to remove
this skill that is supposedly being
useful and make sure that python is
doing its job well the thing is that
since like I said now we have computers
that have multiple cores
imagine if you have a very very heavy
Python program and now you have 10
workers in your computer and you are
only assigning one worker to work on
your very heavy Python program
um what if I can assign the 10 of them
work together to just finish my Python
program so I don't have to sit there
forever right so that sounds great
um so now since like is you just go to
like some other like you know just just
get a laptop you have like multiple call
so we want to make use of that to make
use of the speed that it would benefit
us uh to run our python code faster
but things are not that simple right it
sounds really good but it's not that
simple because there are a lot of
challenge if we try to remove the gear
there's a lot of it's not that
straightforward that we say okay let's
remove the gear and everybody's happy no
it's not that
um
first of all something that uh we need
to care about is that uh it if we remove
the gear right we also make sure that
for people who are still like using a
single thread
they are not going to uh be uh you know
losing out right they are not going to
be like uh you know we sacrifice the
performance for people who are using
single thread but only like optimized
performance for multi-fread no that's
not something that we're doing here
we've got to make sure that it will be
fine for people who are just like prefer
to have the lock right there's it's also
fine so you just like have an extra step
that makes sure that if we're doing
whatever I think it's supported so
um there are a lot of things inside
python how python work that basically uh
need to deal with before we remove the
lock for example there are the reference
counting so reference counting is in
Python that uh when you know you have a
lot of different objects that got
created in a python you know execution
cycle right
um so when something is created you know
some memory is assigned to do this job
or to this to store this object this
value in this object
um so in Python there's also like uh
we're counting you know like whether
this object is still needed how many
other objects I'm referencing this uh so
if nobody's referencing it maybe it's
not useful anymore then we can remove it
right
um so it's reference counting get a
little bit tricky when you have multiple
thread because we are not having one
thread that is accessing and like
managing this excess of object there are
multiples so uh there's like something
that it could be a little bit tricky so
there's a new thing it's called bias
reference counting that was introduced
um also like some uh objects that uh now
are like basically uh you know instead
of doing very complicated reference
counting because we're multiple threat
we just make them Immortal which means
that they would be there forever until
the whole Python program is finished
executing so those things usually are
the most commonly used object like true
and false you know we use that a lot
because we you know if you have written
some python code you know that we have a
lot of if else or true and false is
quite commonly used also some integers
some smaller integers they are also like
quite commonly used so those objects it
will just be there
um we will just no reference counting
and make them Immortals they would be
there all the time there are also some
other things that like for example some
Global functions that basically uh
because you know it's kind of at the top
level so the reference count is going to
be handled separately it will be you
know uh you know deal with uh before the
garbage collection garbage collection is
the step that when you know when the
objects there's no reference counts or
basically they can be recycled so they
are not used anymore so we do the
garbage collection so that's the stage
that like some objects will be dealt
with when it's uh you know the time for
the garbage collection so
um
yeah right so
um design and Challenger so now
um again like for for those are the
things that a few things that I talk
about about the reference counting and
the garbage collection but there's also
other things for example uh if I have
multiple threat they're trying to access
the same object right like I said before
a lot of objects in Python is
um you know immutable so things can be
changed after they are created so what
if two threads try to change at the same
thing
um so in that case instead of using a
global lock that locks the whole program
can be only accessing by one thread we
have to have smaller logs uh which means
that I always always put this analogy is
that instead of for example the global
interpreter log is like you only have
one driver driving a car through the
whole road trip that you only have one
dedicated driver and there's no nobody
else gotta touch the steering wheel but
now it's not like we have actually two
drivers or multiple drivers in this road
trip that we're gonna take turn driving
but uh we have to have an agreement that
like okay when someone's gonna hand over
the driving wheel right in a car it's
very easy it's physical you just like
you know you just stop by some kind of
let's say gas station and like you know
the driver step out of the car and then
sit in the other seat and they are the
new driver come into the driver's seat
right so that's very obvious but in a
program so we need to have other
mechanisms to change driver
um so this this is how we have smaller
lock so only one person is going to
touch the steering wheel at a time but
this uh you know this steering wheel can
be passed around to different drivers so
this uh mechanism only to be written in
the C python itself because right now
how see python work is that um
yeah yeah so I'm just reading the
comments sorry um so uh so uh right now
you know uh when we for example use the
standard version of python it's called C
python so it's inside C python there's a
lot of
um see python API that was written
basically is that uh when python uh
sorry to put it simple so when python
the program see that that line of your
code it will get interpreted as like
okay I'm now doing this for example I'm
doing it if else so I'm going to call
this C code that actually do the same
thing so
and this is how pythony's interpret
right now so with this new design we
have to also have uh some C python API
that basically when we interpret the
code we see that okay now we head over
the driving wheel so we need to write
that down as well
um so that's basically means that more
work need to be done not just that
simple
um also there's something in Python
right now that's called a primal log
which is a uh a allocator uh of
resources and we we're like this is what
python is using now
um but if we are thinking about changing
how python work by removing the gear we
have to use a new log that's called an
email log it's designed by uh Sam's team
uh you know his colleagues to develop I
think he works in meta so it's like it's
so this is an open source technology
that's developed by meta so the more
detail you can you can listen to his
talk and other resources that I will
mention at the end so I'm also for for
the garbage collection it's also you
know because you when we collect the
garbage we make sure that nobody's gonna
try and access it again right so when
something is ready to be collected like
and we thought that nobody's going to be
using it we're gonna have to stop
everybody from actually accessing it
otherwise like we thought this nobody's
using it but suddenly someone's trying
to use it then it's going to be have a
conflict so I need to stop the world for
garbage collection so there are a lot of
new things that actually really need to
be considered and I'm just touching the
service right now and briefly explaining
what's going on as you know uh I'm not
going to into detail here but if you
want to detail I would point you to the
right resources at the end so don't
worry if you think that oh my God
there's too many information I don't
know what you're talking about it's fine
I'm going to point you to the original
Talk by Simon you would understand more
so
so they are all a kind of introduction
of what's going on and why I'm doing
this
um now is uh now is like what fun I have
when I'm trying it right so um
so after I've heard this is oh this
sounds really good fun and I really want
to try it with the thing that I do as a
data scientist you know I was a data
scientist so I do a lot of this kind of
thing I want to see if this is going to
improve the scientific program so
um
uh I have my doubt because you know uh
for those of you who use let's say
sci-fi on numpy a lot you know that in
those package we already have a lot of
optimization done that is we are not
just running pure python code when we
are using those packages in those
package we already have a lot of uh CPI
module which is like you know if you
look at the source code
um there are some file that is actually
end with DOT C pi and those are actually
uh written not in Python it's written C
is kind of like a plug-in to make things
fast for for those kind of code
um also siphon Cipher is also another
tool to uh you know to uh
uh compile some of the code uh that to
make it fast when you execute your code
so
those are already used behind the hood
for those like sci-fi and numpines so we
already have a lot of optimization so
does this Nokia really help us more
um
so let's let's try it right so you never
know until you try it so I'm going to
give it a try
um so I'm going to test it on some
popular scientific process
um
so that that's how I design my
quote-unquote experiment right so it's
not very scientific but it's kind of a
little experiment a little fun that I
had so I want to try on something where
it's like psychic learn I want to try on
something like numpy and sci-fi so those
are the most popular private Library uh
so I want to try on some Neo network but
unfortunately because
um like I said this Library they are
having some kind of external
Library so it's not on pure python they
need to have a built that is matching
your computer right they are compiled
um so for the Nokia version of python uh
for circuit learn numpy and sci-fi those
are available
um to use so that's this brainless is
like straightforward I just like you
know
um use those uh to to do my testing but
uh for other libraries like a tensorflow
or pytorch is more complicated and I
can't get hold of a version that
basically work on the Nokia so I kind of
uh haven't done that yet so maybe I'll
do that in the future who knows
um
so also again like disclaimer my
experiment is not foreign scientific uh
so if some of the result you know it
doesn't actually absolutely represent
anything it's not a conclusion it's just
something I I hope to spark some uh
interests or some thought about it so um
yeah so let's have a look
um oh also by the way I compared a
no-gear version the original three nine
which the Nokia version is coming from
and the newest and shiniest 3.11 version
of python so let's see
oh yeah oh by the way all the other code
I was on GitHub so if you have this
slide that you can click on it and found
the code but all of them are just like
example that I copy from you know the
official uh documentation website from
psyched or numpy and sci-fi so you can
find them and do it yourself so
uh for the first one I try is the
support Vector machine because usually
it takes a lot of time for my code so I
download this example again like from
the official documentation of
scikit-learn is using SPM to recognize
some handwriting I run each of them
around 50 times for average uh you know
the the times I have a little bit more
smooth because you know every time you
run the program there will be like
slight discrepancy depending on you know
what's going on in your computer so I
average it over 50 times so again a more
stable kind of uh measure of how fast
this is
so you see that actually there's no
significant difference in this uh three
different version Oh by the way I was
running this on my old MacBook which is
um quite old it's only got dual core so
uh again like I said I'm buying a new
one so maybe I can test it in a new
computer in the future and there will be
maybe other results that is different
from this but so far for this like old
MacBook with only dual core Intel uh
processors it's like uh no difference
for the svm which is a little bit
disappointing so but I I continue right
so again this is not a conclusion this
is just a start of trying it out so
um I try another one for the clustering
so clustering this I use again another
demo from the Cyclone
documentation and then I found that
again there's no significant difference
between all these different clustering
uh with k-mean or PCA these are usually
very like heavy processes but of course
the example they are you're more
lightweight rather than you know your
real computation will be more heavy but
still there's like no significant
difference so it's a bit disappointing
um
and a decision tree the century is like
very interesting because actually the
3.9 is the fastest I don't know what
happened
um but actually in the in a decision
tree there's a lot of like uh you know
randomization that's going on so maybe
it's just that I got lucky on lucky I
don't know how you can frame it but uh
it's not you know so so like you have a
range of actually the result because
again decision tree is like randomized
so it's
um a bit you know uh difficult to
compare so
um yeah again I don't see there's an
improvement from the Nokia which is a
little bit disappointing uh so for the
linear algebra actually this one the
Nokia version is actually better than
the uh C Python 3 9 which is the
original version that is uh clone from
so
um it's a linear algebra on the N
Dimension array so the example is
actually doing some kind of uh image
processing filtering on the image and
you can see that uh so for this uh
linear algebra actually no gear is
better than three nine but not 311 so
I'm still not the ideal situation I want
to see right now
um oh sorry that was yeah that was
really algebra and this is like uh so
this is uh sorry uh yeah so it's like
some normal transposers I think this is
in the side pie in the Sci-Fi so it's
like the thing and again it makes up
with this image filter so this image
filter is actually image processing on
the um on the numpy arrays so the uh so
you know applying some gaussian filter
and stuff to so it's kind of doing some
image calculation with like different
you know there was a grid of in you know
of numbers and let's do some calculation
there so
it depends on the filter actually the
result varies so for the no Geo you can
see the uh improved money in the
gaussian Futures but for the other
filters actually you know different
standard version of python perform the
best
so uh yeah so the again like the the
result is not conclusive there's just
some spark some kind of
um you know
debate I guess or interest into your
life if you're trying it or you know you
try in your machine which probably be
better than mine and deceive you know
let's say you have a core maybe you'll
be better
um I don't know so
and the last one is again so I said I
want to try it on some uh you know new
network
um so I I can't try on tensorflow or if
I torch those for flow ones so I'll try
on the uh the one that's provided by
psychic learn actually is not it's not
too bad you know because you know MLP
classifiers and uh you know succulent
also provided that so it's a stochastic
learning
um so you see that uh actually again
three nine is the best uh amount of them
it's only average about 10 times because
this learning process is a bit slow so
50 times it would take me ages to finish
so uh so all of this result again like
is not conclusive but it's a bit
disappointing so what happened so
um so along this journey I have I asked
myself
I said not as fast as what I wanted to
um there are a few things that I was
thinking about uh so first of all uh
there are actually discussion about this
new version of Nokia python last year at
this year actually
um in Python us there's like a
maintainer summit so they have
discussions I have some notes which I
will also show you know as a reference
at the end
um so there is like uh this is this
Nokia version it has done a lot of uh
you know Improvement but the thing is
that um you know uh we the the library
that we are using for like for example
psychic learn or numpy they are already
uh having the C extension Improvement so
those are not necessarily affected by
the kill because they are kind of pushed
outside of the Python system they are
already like compiled and they were
written in C code and got compiled so
they they may already be using multiple
thread and it's already quite fast
um also the interface that you know DC
extension talk to python it may not be
the most efficient right now because it
may still uh expecting the deal
and um So eventually if this uh no gear
kind of strategy got adopted in Sea
python the whole thing needs to be
redesigned to adopt this Nokia mode so
that may actually come in become an
issue or a uh or a block to have like
this you know no Guild design that is
adopted as the standard version it would
take still take quite a while to get
there I think
um
also compatibility you know so
it may not it's working it's like
running the program fine but it may not
be optimal because you know again it's
uh the the extensions I'm not expecting
you're running it on a Nokia python
um also my experiment results is not a
very good conclusion because I'm running
it on dual core machine so uh if you
have more core uh if the parallelization
will help in the speed then it will be
uh easier to see if you have more core
because you know if the design is good
then you wanted the Improvement to be
close to linear Improvement so the more
core you have the uh the Improvement
should be more obvious so the last uh
you know this is still a working
progress
um so we should you know not treating it
as the conclusion of like whether it's
useful or not because you know uh
where I would have to end the session
now uh yeah we're at the end of the
session uh can I have like just one
minute to close it up I'll just close it
now
the next speaker will will enter the
room will enter the session
now we have just only 20 seconds
yeah so this is actually the last slide
basically it's the reference uh so if
you get the slice at the beginning uh
you would actually have all this link
and you can check out the talk by Sam
there's like more detail on there and
also the blog post by Lucas which is one
of the C python core maintainers so
there's like more discussion about you
know whether C python with adaptional
gear uh there will be discussion there
so check it out
um I think that's it